[Music]
digital technologies are transforming
many areas of daily life schools and
classrooms are also changing their ways
of teaching by using technology to
support teachers and students but our
schools ready to make the most of
digital technologies for learning
research shows that many things can
still be improved to help schools
realize where they stand in their use of
digital technologies we developed salfi
a free online easy-to-use self
reflection tool taking a selfie of a
school means looking at many different
areas school strategies teaching
practices infrastructure curriculum and
the experience of students we know that
every school is unique that is why
selfie can be customized each school can
select and even add its own questions
and statements to suit as particular
situation through selfies school leaders
teachers and students can express their
views on how technology is used for
teaching and learning hearing the voice
of the whole school community is
essential and its feedback is used to
generate a selfie school report a
snapshot of how digital technologies are
used in that school showing strengths
weaknesses and potential areas for
improvement this report can be used to
start a dialogue within the school
community and to create an action plan
to improve the use of digital
technologies of teaching and learning
all data gathered through selfie is
anonymous I cannot be tracked to
individual schools students or teachers
selphie is the first step in reflecting
where your school stands in digital age
learning and to see what next steps
could be want to know more about selfie
check out our website and be part of the
conversation with the hashtag selfie
underscore EU
[Music]
you